ce vote non je vais pas balancer des
noms
non mais je veux dire que les aider le
ligue 1 le disque vous avez fait grougi
de bardot est pour vous un grand moment
dans votre témoin non plus un disque
mythe c'est un titre mythique et
pourquoi charles trenet dans votre album
quand j'avais 7 8 ans je suis tombé un
mot une petite fille adorables
je sais que je n'ai pas gm cherche
actuellement je n'ai pas ne mange jamais
moi une mémoire extraordinaire surnomme
sur la peau nue enfance et je vois une
petite fille sur une plage et on se
pense en ce thème
c'était mon premier amour et à l'époque
dit ont diffusés par des haut parleurs
des chansons de trenet j'étais dans ma
main qui joue avec qui je viens doigts
j'étais yeux dans mes yeux partout dans
le voir